نحن الان في احدى بلدات منطقه بورونا
الواقعه اقصى الجنوب الاثيوبي المحاذي
لدوله كينيا هذه المنطقه تعاني منذ من
اكثر من ثلاث سنوات لجفاف حاد وشحف
الامطار تسبب في نفوق اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين راس من الماشيه بسبب جفاف هذه
المنطقه وايضا عدم هطول الامطار لثلاثه
اعوام متتاليه كما نرى هنا بعض الجهود
الحكوميه المتواضعه لتزويد السكان بالمياه
من خلال شاحنات ومن خلال هذه
البراميل لتزويد السكان بالمياه بعد ان
جفت كافه منابع المياه
نحتاج المزيد من المياه وما نحصل عليه لا
يكفينا تاتي الشاحنه هنا مرتين في الاسبوع
فقط ولكل اسره كميه محدوده من المياه
يوميا
المجتمع الان يعاني بشكل حاد والناس في
حاله ذعر نفقه الماشيه هنا وهي تعتبر مصدر
غذاء المواطنين ودخلهم نحن هنا لتدخل في
الجانب الصحي وما يتعلق بالتغذيه
الجفاف سوف يستمر الى منتصف هذا العام مما
ينذر بعواقب وخيمه على المتضررين ما لم
يتلقوا الدعم والمساعده اللازمه من كافه
الجهات الغذائيه والخيريه حسن الرزاق
الجزيره من منطقه برونا جنوبيه اثيوبيا